Senate Republicans desperate to move
forward with two of Donald Trump's
cabinet nominees decided to suspend the
committee rules to move forward in spite
of Democrats boycotting this is the
Senate Finance Committee they conducted
the hearings for Steven minuchin the
Treasury secretary selection and
Congressman Tom Price the selection for
Secretary of Health and Human Services
for the second day in a row yesterday
Democrats decided they're not going to
show up they said that the two nominees
made misrepresentations which is
certainly an understatement if I've ever
heard one and under committee rules you
have to have at least one Democrat there
to vote and decide to send the nominee
to the full Senate for confirmation we
had zero Democrats show up specifically
to slow the process down and then
committee chairman Orrin Hatch a Utah
Republican went to lengths that many are
calling tyrannical by saying hey listen
we've got extraordinary circumstances
here so we are just just going to
suspend the rules skip the rules and
let's move forward without any Democrats
here on the vote Democrats are
completely rightly demanding that these
are demanding that's my word I mean
really they're asking for but they want
clarification on some answers from both
price and minuchin but with the two
nominations already being sent to the
full Senate it's very unlikely that
Democrats are going to get the answers
they want this is why Pat Democrats need
to stand in the way of the Supreme Court
nomination of Neel Gorsuch which would
require at least 60 votes to break a
filibuster Mitch McConnell is very
clearly one of the worst in the Senate
remember he refused to have hearings for
President Obama's Supreme Court pick
Merrick garland and then yesterday he
throws around all sorts of threats and
criticism saying hey wait a second
Democrats are gonna stand in the way of
president Trump's nomination and we have
the exact same scenario here where they
obstruct for years and frame it as the
moral thing to do they're in power for a
week or two and now they say hey now the
moral thing to do is to skip the rules
because it's the Democrats that are
obstructing you couldn't have bigger
hypocrites it's just hilarious to hear
these Senate Republicans talk about how
the Democrats are breaching protocol
I mean Orrin Hatch even called the
Democrats idiots I mean they have struct
adobea for six years and there wasn't
really much retribution for it now to
act holier-than-thou on this is is
really just a bad thing it's absolutely
pathetic it's not credible it's not
believable and this is one of those
areas where particularly for these
Senate Republicans on the on the
committee the Finance Committee who are
in lower population red states start
calling up their offices called their DC
office and their state offices and say
I'm a voter and I'm disgusted by how
senator whatever handled the rules
situation in the Senate Finance
Committee I will not be voting for them
in the next election and I will be
encouraging everyone I know not to vote
for them because every single one of
those calls and please call don't email
it is considered to represent a
significant number of constituents and
this is actually one of those areas
where calling your legislators can make
a difference get on the phones and say
you will not stand for nor support
someone who just blatantly ignores what
the rules are within these committees